quit as a new app where you can collect
exclusive digital sticker cards and toys
for free featuring all the shows who
likes such as Breaking Bad Adventure
Time Star Trek and most importantly Game
of Thrones this app has a lot of Game of
Thrones collectibles and the best thing
about it is if you're a person who likes
ending emojis and stickers with this app
you can put the Ned Stark Daenerys
Targaryen or Tyrion Lannister stickers
there text or you can also collect cards
they made a pretty fun game of
collecting them til you open up packs of
stickers and cards and it kinda brings
me to the days of opening football cards
as a kid so when you get the app make
sure you add me as a friend my username
is fire and blood and if I have
something you're not able to unlock we
can make trades together and there's
also chat for Game of Thrones community
so we can trade with other people who
use Game of Thrones stickers you can
also showcase your collection by adding
stickers to anything on your camera roll
link and my username will be down below
in the description so feel free to check
it out it's available for iOS and
Android but it's not as smooth on
Android yet since it's still in beta and
also quick sidenote new stickers cards
and figures that you can collect for
free or release every day if your Game
of Thrones nerd just like I am then
you're really gonna what this app and
the best thing about it is it's free use
the link in the description and give it
a try and don't forget to add me as a
friend
hey guys after capturing eulerian teen
euro rage I proudly delivered them to
Cersei Lannister as his promised gift
eventually we find both Thane and her
mother being chained to the wall of a
dungeon to facers is just as for
murdering her daughter Cersei poisons to
Hima the long farewell to our kids just
as Illyria head down to marcela the long
farewell is a poison originating from a
shy and as its name implies it takes
some time to take effect but it's highly
lethal without causing the certain death
it's also porn - how odd that long
farewell is the only known poison whose
antidote has been presented then deal
successfully with this being said lime
introduced with a theory in which Diane
will not die and her beautiful face will
not crumble to bone and dust but will
rather be saved by Bronn there are
actually quite a few hints from the
previous seasons that are going favor to
this theory let's start with the fact
that bran was poisoned by the same
poison in the fifth season by Tyne
herself battalion was also the one to
save his life as she provided him
an antidote throughout the series Brown
became quite rich but as he said himself
while he does have plenty of gold he
doesn't have castles nor lands in the
seventh episode of the fourth season
Brown ends for Tyrion summons whereupon
Tyrion tried to persuade him into being
his champion in a trial by combat
however Cersei already arranged for him
to marry Lolly's Stokeworth as a bribe
to sway him from helping Tyrion
even though bran was satisfied with the
arrangement because he'll become a minor
nobleman and would assure that his wife
would eventually inherit Castle
Stokeworth bran still heard out earrings
after bran reminded Tyrion of promise to
offer him double forever anyone that
wanted to sell him out was offering
despite earrings offer of a possible
portion of the north
Brunell debt it was unlikely the Tyrion
will ever control north through Sansa
and therefore he declined his offer if I
emerge from this with my head still on
my shoulders I may one day rule the
north in her name I could carve you out
a big piece of it if and May and could
his bloody cold up north however not
long after Cersei has arranged for
villas Bracken to Wed Lolly's instead of
him which angered bran Jaime on the
other hand promised bran that he will
get a much better girl and a much bigger
castle once they return from Dorne which
hasn't been fulfilled in the seventh
episode of the previous season bran
reminded Jaime of his promise sent his
yet to receive any you promised me a
lordship and a castle and a highborn
beauty for the wife and you'll get all
three a Lannister oh don't say however
bran would get himself everything he was
promised by saving tahini not only that
he would save a life of a woman who back
in the fifth season saved his life from
the same poison but he would also get
himself a highborn beauty for the wife
huge castle and entire Dorne as stain
will become a new ruler well bronze said
that he wouldn't like to live in the
north where his bloody cold dorrance
climate on the other hand is quite
opposite don't wait too long a
noblewoman to marry back home
in my opinion this outcome in which
Brown would say tie in the same way she
saved him by providing her an antidote
whereupon he would sneak her out and
together would escape to Dorne monster
only doesn't sound out of the realm of
possibilities
additionally those few scenes between
those two characters that seem to be
quite unnecessary
especially tie-ins flirting with Brown
at the docks the whole story about
visiting him before he marries a
nobleman would actually be a for Shara a
bronze saving her life this time and
noblewoman that Brown said he has to
marry back home would actually be tying
herself